Mark: Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to T hree Scary Games now
we're starting off with one called Lady Ice that was made during
The Asylum Jam a while back
And it's been on Itch.io for awhile Game: Michigan was full of work lots of farms and cattle it needed men
And they were right work was plenty during the summer months, but hard during the winter
Mark: Oh shit
Game:The storm doesn't just prey on the weak,
all men are equal when the land freezes over
I've seen men stronger than horses freeze in minutes after getting caught in the blizzard, and the ones that do survive
they live in fear of Lady Ice *THUNDER*
Mark: OH fuck!
Some folks say she's nothing more than a tall tale...others say she might have been something once
but now was nothing more than whispers,
a ghost story that fathers tell their children to keep them out of the storm
But when she comes knockin'
those folk won't be telling any stories
Mark: Oh no why?!
Game: cuz sun's setting, so stoke the fires, light a candle. It doesn't matter what you do
So long as you
stay
out
the dark.
Mark: Stay out the dark!? Stay out the dork?
*Startled Mark noise* "Lady Ice no!" You're locked inside your cabin, you must survive until the storm passes. "Well shi-i-it."
"Okay, all right, I'm down. Holy shit. Left-click to light your candles keep them lit and stay in the light to stay safe. Alright."
"Oh boy, what happens if I go in the dOrk?
Wha-ha-hat? Uh-oh.
Uh-uh-uh-uh-uh. Oooo..ah."
"Hold shift to- Oh my god, my god damn candles! *Mark noise* Hold shift to sprint away from danger. How do I know what dan-" *spooky noise*"-AHH!"
"'Scuse me. Oh my god!"
"Uh- You can't light your candle until the dark spell pa-. I literally tabed out of the game. *Mark noises*"
"I hate it! I hate it! The Ice Lady can use her spell four times before the storm is over. I don't know what that means.
Can I just go??
Ah-AH! Oh-oh. *Mark noises*" *Ice Lady laughing*
"Okay. *Chuckles*"
*spooky noise* Wow."
"Not bad I mean it uses stock unity assets or stuff."
"That's publicly available, but what they did with it is actually quite impressive. I am very impressed."
"All right, let's try this again. Holy hell. Hold shift to sprint away from danger."
"I'm gonna sprint so far away from Lady Ice. Lady Ice ain't gonna get me! Lady Ice can go suck a cock!" *Mark noises*
"No, my barrels-  AHHH!!!" *Ice Lady laughing*
"Oh no no- I did it-
"Oh, I see, did I block up the door, and that's how she got in? Well shit, Imma fucking idiot."
"Alright well look- Okay Lady Ice I'm ready for you. Whatever you're thinking. Just don't do it."
Whatever you're thinking Don' Do It! Don' do it- I see you Lady Ice"
"I saw that I saw that- I can't light until you get away, right? Oo-oo-oh."
"Okay, all right. Okay. Oh, I see you, okay. I just got to stay away."
Oh god I can't see anything.
Oh god, where are you? Okay, I see you okay, all right. I'm just gonna run circles around you!
*Mark noise* Okay.*Repeats: Can't see.*
"I hear her oh, hey wow!!!" *Ice Lady laughing-
Mark laughing*
What a good joke lady Ice you pretending that you're hi hello I see-
Okay, I don't like that
Wait you're still in here wait
wait
Wait a minute wait
But that's not okay
okay, well here here. She'll be coming round the mountain when shE COMES
oh, I didn't see where she was
I was here. I was here. I don't like that. I don't see her
Where she I don't know where she is Oh there hello, hi okay?
*knocking*
Huh lady ice don't do it. Don't do it. Did you?
Fuckin' lady ice fuck off
That's terrifying
that's goddamn terrifying
Terrifying
Alright lady ice okay lady ice let's all calm down here
Lady ice I got the fear burps come on come at me lady ice
more like lady ass
You in here? you're in here aren't ya
Where are you? I don'tSee you see you see I don't like it
There yard there you okay, no no no
Not today, you can knock my furniture all up
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh?
Shit okay all right, this is fine
So what happened last time did I just not run away from her correctly
Cuz it seems like oh shit. Yeah, you're still here fuck butts
Sorry I got scared I legitimately II got terrified oh boy. Oh, no no no whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa?
I don't know. I don't know
No, no
No, no,NO,no okay. She charged. I think I
Think that's what that was she charged
Two times nothing about there being four times how am I gonna survive four times if this bullshit? Oh, hey well that was close?
It's totally fine just kids
You and me
It's just going to flip that over so I didn't run over it, I'm gonna hit oh shit
Light the fuckers light the fuckers, ohh shit, what's even the point who aren't even the point the point
But that was a lot closer than I thought it'd be
Three times, we'll that's good to know
There's a five three
Big three big three baby. Oh, yeah, yeah, that is the worst thing I've ever seen
No, no no no no oh
Boy, she seems to be stuck in the middle. She's like coming towards me, and then I don't know man. I don't know oh
It's whenever I run to the darkness. That's when she that's when she comes for me. Oh I see
Okay all right oh shit
No no no oh that's not good, that's no no no
No no no no no, I don't like the music
No, oh shit, oh shit
Mark's: Warrior yell*
Gonna make it
Did I survive?
Did I win
I won
Survived the storm, they'll be telling stories about you usually they tell stories about you when you're dead okay
But I won that's all that matters, okay
Holy fuck
Holy shit. Okay. All right well goddamn. That was terrifying
Anyway, that was Lady ice what a start? What a start to this gear this video. Oh my god all right, okay?
Okay, this next one's gonna be a wonky one
It's not exactly a horror game as far as I know so the game in this is quit the game to win
Oops
Escaping all four won't work either. Won't they oh they won't they don't work there
No work sure. There's the task manager, but that's cheating that way. You'll kill the process now KITT the game
What about that X button at the top-right corner? Oh?
You fucking oh you fucker. Nope there must be a way to touch it X no I
Think it just needs a friendly approach be gentle, okay
Okay, let's try some real-
That's funny, I don't think it's working I don't think it's working either, okay?
I
Think we scared it off. Yeah, I think so too here. Take this it surely looks better. Oh
We didn't do nothing wait, where did it go
I guess it's hiding somewhere. Maybe it's a shy one try calling its name. I'm not an object. Oh
All right, try calling him by his name. I'm a sheath
Fine would you trees please calling her by her name?
Her
Ex
X  X  X
We got it, I mean her now click on her
Did we just win
No crap. I guess we didn't okay
Here we go again. We were so close wait. I have an idea when the lights went off
I think I saw something. Oh god. I hope I didn't say something like a switch behind the title the circuit breaker not the console
Anyway, try moving the title down under this text box
What do I what do I have to move it over the text box, I'm gonna move it above it. Oh, okay, I see alright
So that was the main power switch
What's that dangly thing I don't trust that dangly thing
Huh, there's a blinking light now well
Progress, I guess which is good. Maybe I don't know looking uh no oh
I don't like that. Oh, I don't like that at all oh
Okay, that's fine alright. Okay, what's going on?
Wait don't touch that button
I just realized something important killing the process is quitting the game and that means I'll cease to exist
How could you push that button how can you kill the process after all the time we spend together after all the jobs we faced
How could you kill me okay fine? I won't interfere with your choices
Oh, I think this music is interfering with my choice
Kill the process well this sad music won't affect me bitch a-loyd get ready to get fucked oh
Did you really think it was that simple nobody's gonna kill me you're not gonna win this game. I won't win this game
God damn it fuck you fuck you fine. Whatever okay? All right?
So that wasn't exactly a scary game, but I'll keep that in anyway. It was funny. All right. Let's play let's find two more
Okay
Welcome to Dora is not dead
Not Dora is dead. This is made by the same guy that made that Curran scary game. I'm pretty sure
All right
So Dora is either dead or not dead, and I don't know which is worse find a way out okay clear and cut his kid
All right well
Then it's either made by the same guy that made that or it's made by the same guy that made 3:00 a.m.
At the Krusty Krab and then again, maybe those are all the same. I don't honestly don't know I found a way out I
think
Follow the trail of blood, and I'm gonna find where Dora ain't dead
Okay
Found it again. This looks like my way out find the gate key easy breezy, easy
peasy lemon squeeze me huh I've got chills down my spine who knows what lurks behind the darkness I
have a funny feeling I know what lurked behind the darkness and it took someone by the name of dora
Or something that may or may not have tried to kill Dora at some point
What the fuck did you say, oh no was that DorA
No
Who's this a gun a hammer that'll come in handy
Okay, alright, okay?
Oh-oh-oh-oh okay, no
Use a hammer on the blanks, I'll use a hammer on the blades. I got a key good good good
Good dad, but smash that like button
Okay fine
I don't know if it's catching up to me, but I got a bad feeling about this, okay
Whoa-ohh-ohh get in okay? We're fine. Oh ha that was weird. What was that?
What did I see on the wall uh?
okay, I
Guess we're fine did we make it did we what is that?
What is that? I think I have everything at oh, no, it's the map that bitch killed me now your next Swiper
Oh, I'm the Swiper. Oh
No, they warned me about swiping. Oh, I knew it was gonna go over me if I kept up my life of swiping
If I can get out of here alive, I'll never swipe again never Swiper good, but the key doesn't fit
I
Should have known the door was screwing with me. Oh?
The real gate key must be around here somewhere yeah, I guess it shouldn't I shouldn't have trusted the door
That said the key was inside, Oh god ha ha ha
All right, we're fine, okay, never mind
We're not fine. All right Dora if you could just leave me alone for two seconds all right
I'm gonna find wherever that corpse was I guess maybe that's gonna have an answer to me. Oh
What the fuck?
Well, that's the naughty children's room oh, that's the dead dude whatever room
ohh boy
It's hilarious oh this game can actually be scary. I mean it's not that scary admittedly what the fuck is this you're gonna
I'm gonna tear your guts out and devour I'm like a savage
Okay, all right like a savage in a good way or like a savage in a rar rar rar way oh?
Fuck okay, no, I will not help you do your room and dance. Oh my god that scared the piss out of me
Holy shit, at least it seems like Dora can't catch me. What is this is this way? No. This is a different way. Oh?
Oh leave me alone dad. I just want to swipe your key
Is that so wrong?
Oh, I'm not gonna be able to get out of here. Oh real Genki. I hope well. Oh shit. Oh shit. Okay. I'm fine
Don't do it I hope I can get around here
nobody can get around I
think anyway
Why wouldn't I be able okay fine all right perfect the game designer really smarted up the place and really made this intuitive
So I could get away
What the back fuck you monkey fuck you what the fag
fucking monkey
Okay, all right. I think I'm good. Oh, let me out here, huh?
i escaped
Okay
Alright, im outa here, fuck you
Okay anyway Wow alright alright well that was a spook and a half, but now we've got another game by the name of
Lonely things and the artwork that I saw for this game was just creepy as hell watch the introduction yeah
I'll watch it come on. What you got for me. Oh I gotta do this
I've been driving for so long that I couldn't remember where I was going
Yeah, the roads all looked the same the shadows out there never got any closer
It seemed like that night would never end if I just kept going on
All I wanted was a place to sleep, but had been hours since I'd even seen a gas station
I was about to pass out at the wheel when something began to take shape ahead a
building
Couldn't believe my luck
It looked like a hotel
Something tells me this may not be a hotel
Press escape to open the menu. Ah now this is just a demo
For a game that's gonna be a full indie horror game at some point go okay. I'll go I'll go
It's
Real is this like an animal skin rug? Why does this look like an animal skin rug and what animal was this?
Freaking big cuz that don't look like no normal carpet. Oh
Hi, what the fuck? Hi hello? Holy shit. You scared the piss out of me. Hi
Ding ding dong hi. Oh my god. What the fuck?
you're
welcome
Right oh, you poor thing you look like you're about ready to drop you want a room well
I already did the books for tonight. I suppose there isn't any place else for you to go out there, though
Go ahead up to room 12. We can settle up in the morning, okay
Thank you just commenting on your lovely rug beyond
All right room 12. I don't know what room 12 would be but okay locked all right?
Locked okay, all right in by process of elimination
Good great room. Oh, that's that's weird. That's weird
That's weird, that's weird, huh?
Okay everything's fine. Okay, what a shit?
What a shit hole
I opened it great. I'll just lay my head to rest I
Don't get any sheets or nothing. That's good. Hi
Hello, there's someone in your ho Oh
What the fuck
The bar is open grace wants some company your car is gone now
The bar is open now. Where is the bar who is Grace? Oh? She's gone
Oh, hi fucking good fucking god. Stop that shit. Oh
my god
Evening looks like something's troubling you your car was stolen wow I guess that makes you stranded on you don't have any hands
I'll keep an ear out for you. It's Joe. By the way. I've got a lot on my mind myself
I'm waiting on a special lady. Hey, you know grace. I know left in your room. Huh grace does that sometimes?
She's but she's an honest woman. Maybe you could try asking the manager about your car although
Although what?
My god
Grace is that you grace no my special lady's not here Joe wait weren't here decisions
She's really here by now in the coroner table over there. She looks so beautiful in candlelight
I had a bottle of sleepy al for him
I thought she might even let me sit with her with the manager that creep. He took it from me
At least it must have been him
He was hanging around outside my room upstairs earlier said he was fixing the lights what a bunch of bull
Nothing ever gets fixed around here
Okay
All right
Lied nothing to light it with okay
Okay
Joe Oh Joe's not there anymore, that's strange okay
Where is my car?
Where's my car? Where's my car the only parking space? Where is my car?
Okay, well I am perturbed. I am weirded out bing-bong hello
Can I get some service can I get some goddamn service here?
Okay weird oh?
I can go in here oh
Don't trust that at all okay
All right, well, that's weird. Oh. Hi. Why oh hi, okay? All right? I don't like that
Like that you fixing the lights where did I just go I didn't mean to go in there?
Okay it got quiet again
Okay
Let's go, let's go in the private room
Oh
Grace
Hello oh
Whoa? Oh don't get up. Do not get up. Who the hell are you I don't know anything about a stolen car
Talk to Terrance. He's the manager. It's not my job. You'll probably find him somewhere else so get out of here already
No
Hey again. Hey me again. You know my I read your letters. Do you lady all right? Hey me again?
Thanks for not telling dad. I've been writing not much. It's changed since I wrote last time
I pretty much clean rooms sit around listening to music all day sometimes stuff happens. You get some real freaks around here
I found this plan or something under my bed when I was cleaning the room one today
Wasn't the grossest thing I found in that drunk lady's room
There's probably the weirdest it moved never seen a planet do that before I showed it to Terrence anyone all quiet took it from me
And ran off from his office hasn't come out since the old guy's losing his mind ever since his wife disappeared
I'll tell you that another time I've been finding him talking to himself wandering around the halls in the middle of the night
I wonder what he thinks I'm doing it's been three months now since that piece of shit dumped me by the side of the road
Terrence gave me a good deal, so I don't have much to pay for another few weeks
And I'll have enough to move to the city. I don't know what I'm gonna do when I get there though
I'm actually starting to kind of like this place. Don't ask me why I'll write again soon
Hope you aren't still sick Jane so Jane is it
I told you to go away fucking people in this place well alright, then see Jane. Sorry. You don't mind if I scoop around
Alright, well that what I thought I saw something
This games getting to me, which is weird considering. It doesn't seem like all that much on the surface
That's pretty good
alright, so
Terrence have you seen Terrence
Special ladies not here alright. Whatever. Maybe one of the other rooms are Oh, the other rooms are open. Oh shit. Oh, oh oh
This floor looks like skin. Yeah, well, that's weird
Listen man's voice mm-hmm is someone there. I've gotten myself stuck in here somewhere can't find my way out
What what do you mean in the intercom versus an air vent it's hopeless. I'm afraid. I should just accept reality
Things around here have gotten worse lately so come back and talk to me sometimes. Okay, it takes my mind off the noises
Okay, back already. I'd love to talk, but I can't think of anything I'd say right now. Maybe a little later. Oh
Okay
All right that is fucking bizarre
That's so weird
That's so weird. Oh, that's so weird. It's just stuck in the wall, okay
Sure, let's go with okay
It's got to be another room that I can go in if I can go on now
And then other ones must have opened up, right?
From one. They said something about the lady in room one you had a disgusting plan under her bed
No, no, what's with these doors. They're slanted
Switch Oh
What oh
Okay, oh this thing this doesn't seem like an office. Oh, no I
See the manager or something weird happening
What the fuck?
What is happening? I got a key no. I don't I got sloppy out sleepy out not sloppy al
All righty, then I'm sure the manager whoa ah
That's the plant
Okay, well let's just close that
Pretend I never saw it
Okay, all right. Wow. It's a ship on this sea
Lovely all right. I'm out of here. I'm going to get this sleepy out okay. I'm right here now great
Okay, let's get the bottle of sleepy all over to this guy so he can impress his fine lady grace my special lady's not here
She was here in the corner table had a bottle of sleepy owl for it okay. He took it from me all right
Whatever what am I supposed to do for it? Then do I?
Put the sleepy owl here there. We go okay, so I need something to light that with too because I'm setting the hill
No he was hanging at my room, okay?
All right, whatever you say man. Whatever you say if I leave and then come back
maybe or do I still need to find something to light it with ah
Room nine key, okay, I could pick up that key. I just wasn't able to pick it up right away, okay?
I got the room nine key. That's good. Room nine was next to my room I believe
Okay, so there's got to be something to light something with over there right or else that'd be stupid and apparently I'm wrong
Which is an entirely possible possibility?
Lights out, baby
Okay, I got a lighter
What do I do with the lighter
Anything oh, hey cool soap pickle soap can I oh, it's moving?
Gross
Okay, never mind, then okay. I'll leave what the fuck was that
Huh this is like a leech or a slug. Why was it in a medicine cabinet?
No, whatever I'll go light the candle, and then I'll go talk to the dude. Maybe he'll have something else to say oh
Sure Boinky
Oh
Okay, hi grace. Hey, oh
Yeah, yeah, uh-huh yeah, how's it hanging? How you doing grace? That's my favorite drink? How did you know? I'm grace
Someone stole your car huh? Well the good news is that means you can have a drink with me. Maybe not here, though
It's a little crowded. We could go up to my room. Here's the key I'm in room 1
It's right above us you haven't been there before right no of course. Sorry ignore me
Just meet me there in a little while okay?
Oh, and if the manager asked what you're doing don't mention me he has ideas about how people should behave
Right all right
What do you think about that you think I didn't hear that so you think you're just gonna swoop in on my special lady
Right in front of me. Huh who the fuck do you think you are?
Well i'ma go up to a room then. That's who the fuck
I think I am the guy who was given a key to her room. Haha. I'm sure this isn't gonna
Go poorly for me. I'm gonna get laid and that's all there is to it definitely not just a horrible vampire
hmm
I'm gonna go with the horrible vampire thing. Oh hello
I'm sorry to slip a note under your door like this, but why don't we talk anymore that night a few weeks ago?
I told you I loved you and you said you loved me too. Now you act like you don't even remember
I can't stand seeing you in the bar talking to those other men. They're all just trying to take advantage of you
You know I'll keep my distance like you asked, but I don't want you to think I've forgotten about you grace
I know you're in some kind of trouble is it Terrence? He's been hanging around outside your room. Maybe that's why you've been so distant
Don't worry. I'll keep an eye out, Joe
Umm
All right
*mix of fear and confusion"
I fell down?
Whoa oh
You're a slug now. You're a slug. You're a slug now. You're uh. You're you're uh. Oh, there's a slug here too, okay?
Oh oh
Oh, you really felt. Oh you felt you fell down. Oh, okay. I'll go in the hole in the
What the fuck oh
Hi hello, oh never mind you know what bail bail bailing on that Oh bail bail
Oh Christian Bale
Place you need to put something. He would want you to put well look at that puzzle II need to put there. Oh god
I keep getting stuck on the corners. Yeah, hello. Hi oh no oh no. Oh, no oh
Oh, oh, okay, you know what never mind
Okay, oh, oh, hi Joe. How are you doing Joe? Oh?
She's dead why did she do that?
Um I don't think she did that it won't be long now. It's coming for me
I've been like this my whole I've never knew any other way to be the truth is I just hate it all
There's no pain no trauma
There's nothing I'd rather be than a quiet drunk
Nobody ever really wanted to understand that at least here people never bothered me till you Joe
You just won't leave me alone, so I'm not gonna pretend anymore. The only way out is down
Oh my god
Okay, I got the plant then
You know what I don't know Joe. I don't know why she did that but something tells me, I probably give
Them does me I got a place this plant over here, all right yay yay for me
oh
Boy, thank you
Oh no
Oh boy
Hi whoo hey let's go in there oh oh hi, oh hi
Hello, everybody my name is markiplier. How are you doing it? Okay? Whoa Wow yeah?
I know you're all staring at this house. Here is very lovely knock knock
Oh fucking hi hello, this isn't the place for you oh?
This is the end of the demo
im scared
I'm scared of laughing cuz I'm nervous
Alright so anyway. Thank you very much for playing
Please keep an eye out for the full game will be released later in 2018 that was really something
It was really simplistic on its surface, but what it had was intrigue like it had
Characters that were fascinating in very short time you got to like understand these characters, and and it really
Gave this concept of something like dreadful in this place
and
That's hard to do when everything's so simplistic so I really applaud the creator this and I really hope to see something cool come out
of this later because I would love to play it that was honestly terrifying just cuz it was so disconcerting and the people were just
Weirdly made enough that they were terrifying so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know he thought these games down in the comments below if you want to play any of them like I always do there
Are links in the description the that provide links straight to the games themselves so thank you so much and as always
I'll see you in the next video
BA BYE
(Outro starts playing)